uh
mom I could
yeah because Mia I'm awake Northwest
pranks Kim Kardashian into thinking she
shaved off her eyebrows
North this is not funny yeah it's not
funny it's hilarious I'm really freaking
out on Sunday Kim's daughter pulled off
an epic joke on her mom and documented
the whole thing on Tick Tock having kids
is just there's no way to describe it
but it's a lot check out northie
carrying a pink eyebrow razor into her
mom's bedroom moving the razor up and
down on Kim's thick brows then North
asks her mama to wake up
see
North this is not funny yeah before Kim
can open her eyes North switches on a
filter that makes her eyebrows look way
thinner than they actually are and Kim
well when she sees her reflection she's
not here for it
North this is not funny clearly North
thought it was funny because she
captioned the clip quote the fake
eyebrows filter that's so funny haha you
just gotta roll with it of course this
is just the latest installment of Epic
content from the mother daughter Duo
last month North put her makeup skills
to the test transforming him into the
Grinch just in time for Christmas You're
a Mean One Mr Grinch she really isn't a
beauty and she loves a little bit of
makeup impressive right
nice kid check your character since then
the two have been getting into the
holiday spirit and spreading the cheer
on social media it's always so much fun
oh the weather outside is
so delightful that's Kim baking some
festive cupcakes with her daughter
complete with lots and lots of sprinkles
so cool the two shared some sweet
musical moments lip syncing to the
holiday hit Santa baby santa baby so
hurry down the chimney tonight and a
remix of sleigh ride
[Music]
North gave fans an inside Glimpse at the
family's holiday Decor which includes
many I mean many Christmas trees and the
family's elves who got into some serious
Shenanigans all over the house
my house is so full but in the best way
of course Kim and north have shared tons
of quality content since launching their
joint Tick Tock account last year why
not but turns out they've actually been
making tick tocks in secret since 2020.
North has a private Tick Tock account so
we we do lots of tick tocks together and
she puts them in drafts she's not
allowed to post them but we have lots of
tick tocks I might post one soon and
since going public it's been nothing but
gem after gem sometimes even at Kim's
expense
North this is not funny
[Music]